hello everyone and welcome to the
tiebreaks of the practice first of all
the Masters Edition we already said that
after we did lost is a final round game
to a young shoot of Duda five players
were were tied for first place but only
two can go into tiebreaks for the
playoffs so with it versus the future
now it's gonna be really really
interesting because with it pretty much
destroyed future in classical time
format he was already lost after 12
moves it was a really really funky line
but fallujah is number six in the world
well he was a sixth in the world blitz
championship last year and he was also
second in the world rapid championship
so faster time controls who really do
favor him and if you've ever watched the
Lita's bullet arena or something like
that you know that he as you know the
lower the time controlled the deadlier
fallujah is so let's see how how wid it
plays in in this blitz game so they will
play a to blitz game match it's a 5
minutes plus 3 seconds increment and if
the 2 games end in a draw after the 2
games have been played if the result is
equal then they go into Armageddon so
let's see what happened this is blitz
game number one but it has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 with Knight
to f6 by Pharaoh just c4 e6 Knight of
three and of course we go into the
Queen's Gambit the client we have d5 and
g3 now we have Bishop to b4 with check
the shop the b2 blocking and Bishop to
e7 now Bishop the g2 now if you in
carrying the light square bishop castles
and with it also castles we have c6
strengthen in the center and Queen to c2
nicely developing the Queen 9b d7 and b3
now so very slow development will be six
preparing to fiend get to the light
square Bishop as well and Bishop to c3
now putting the bishop to this diagonal
I will Bishop to b7 white black does the
same Knight bTW to now we may be
preparing e4 in some lines with Queen to
c7 developing the Queen connecting rooks
and now there is one game where Bishop
to b2 was played I sort of preparing
rook c1 at some point you want to
capture here and have some pressure
along the C file and there is also one
game where
four was played right away but here we
have rook F to D one it's a new move but
then it's already after move 12 we have
a completely new game so let's see let's
see what happens here
Fallujah starts with c5 and it makes
sense if your opponent allows it you
should you should play it a grab more
space in the center free up your light
square bishop we rook 8 2 c1 and now d
captures and c4 opening up this diagonal
and now if you go for B captures and c4
you might be a bit displeased with
yourself leaving you your position with
an isolated c1 for example after
captures captures might be hard to
defend this let's say captures captures
a true kc8 it's an isolated C pond you
also have an isolated a pond so probably
you will have some problems defending
this especially in a blitz game so
Knight captures and c4 instead we have
b5 now pushing the knight back but first
Bishop to a5 displacing the Queen and
now well Quintus c6 is possible you
don't really have to worry about this
night ever moving but in the Blitz game
you do not want to put your queen in
front of the bishop so Queen back to b8
and on tonight's CTE 5 an excellent
square for the knight a we have Knight
captures D captures and Knight to d5 now
and better back to d2 you could be
worried about b4 maybe maybe trapping
your - upon 85 so the shabak to d2
grabbing control of the g5 square h6
taking away the g5 square from White's
pieces and now with it says ok the Queen
and rook aren't really doing all that
much on the Queen side this is a well d5
point is protected let's start an attack
on the King side with the g4 h4 + g5 so
he starts with the g4 we have Queen to
d8 now future now sorry about that
sorry about that there was someone at
the door
so Quinta yet future planning f5 he
wants to bring the Queen into the game
after he pushes f5 and now
h4 still keeping with this plan with f5
it's a well it's a very bold move as it
does create some weaknesses in the
position but it's a blitz game so
whatever works so e captures an f6 on
pass on 9th captures on f6 and now g5
and here g5 definitely a movie you want
to play although here it's a bit
premature problem is the future has this
trip to e4 move which will slow down
with its attack so before g5 nights the
if I was a bit better because it really
just puts night to a much better Square
and there's a well you want to get rid
of the light square bishop and then you
push g5 but ok like I said it's a blitz
game we have g5 Bishop to g4 attacking
the Queen
so the whites attack slows down a bit
Queen to be two and now Knight to g4 and
here already feels just pieces are are
doing good work the f2 pawn is a bit
well
now vulnerable now if the knight moves
then already the route can jump down to
the attack
so Bishop the c3 variate adds another
attacker to the pawn and now Queen to g6
of course defending and now rook d7 a
very nice rook lived by with it and rook
to f7 defending we have Queen tabby to
now adding more well adding protection
to the g5 pawn and also putting more
pressure to the D file h5 % g 5h
captures on g5 and now what happens here
so you could even pause the video and
try to find try to find well we could
even say a winning idea for for Fallujah
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting Bishop
captures on f3 it's a move that really
comes to mind because well you just want
to remove the defender of the g5 pawn it
does make sense the problem is in a
blizzard game where both of them are
and time you have to calculate a lot so
yes this does seem to be working
after captures captures and captures the
queen is under attack the roof is under
attack however there's the rook captures
on f7 that's the problem another problem
but you it requires additional
calculation Bishop captures nd - now you
capture with Czech Queen captures the
Queen's get traded off Bishop captures
on c1 and now F captures and g4 opens up
an attack to the rook rook d8 and now
you move the bishop and now it's two
bishops against the bishop and the roof
four points each and black black is of
course winning here but well you know
when the tension is high it's hard to
calculate everything precisely so Queen
to h5 instead if the knight moves now
you also have X access to the h2 square
and here again it's not easy to find a
move for very probably best is to just
wait with Bishop to b2 you can also now
maybe maybe create an attack this way
because this for example captures
captures an Queen HD check doesn't
really do anything for black you don't
have a way of actually continuing the
attack and white will just be better
here so here with it to try the rook
captures on e7 it's a very active idea
rook captures and now Queen to d6
attacking futures roof on d7 on e7
yeah and now Luke back to f7 we have
Queen captures on e6 now pinning the
rook the queen is on an excellent
squared the bishop is under attack so
Bishop to f5 pushing the Queen back and
now Queen to c6 attacking the rook and
here we have rooked the c8 again
attacking the Queen you could grab upon
but still in a Bulls game you don't just
grab a ponceau Queen to d5 again
centralizing the Queen pinning the rook
once again and here rook to e8 piling up
on the e2 pawn but viddied continues
playing very active chest Queen to c6
attacks the rook and basically forces
him to capture on e2 which future does
we look out for sunny - and now rook to
d1 not even caring about the f2 pawn
video just says okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
go for it we have rook captures on f2
and now we have rooked d8 with check and
now bestest rook the f8 but it's hard to
figure
why so after King 2h7 feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea for visit while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations it's it's
not an easy move to find especially when
you're low on time
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy a show its Queen to a 8
interestingly village played Queen to d8
Quinta yet with the idea of Queen to a
trade check but for some reasons Quinta
a8 is much stronger because we're gonna
show why here Quinta a8 you're already
threatening rook to a cheat with just
the rook captures here so after after a
pretty forced line rook captures an f3
you want to remove the defender go after
Queen to h2 so you force this rook the
h8 but then already you're just down too
much material King g6 but again it
requires a lot of calculation Queen to
see sex with check you're gonna block
with something you have to route
captures on h5 rook captures and c3 now
G captures on f6 now King captures an F
on h5 and now it's a not ok it's still a
queen and bishop against a queen two
rooks and against two rooks and the shop
the problem is you have Queen e8 which
basically wins the rook unless you play
Bishop to g6 but now F captures and g7
threatens promotion and after rook
captures now finally you have Queen tha
check which will win the rook unless
you're gonna block and then you pick up
the c3 Brooke and now it's a Queen and
Bishop against the rook and Bishop of
course completely winning but it's hard
of course to spot this in a blitz game
but as it is a beautiful line I decided
to show it so Queen to eat instead by
with it this Knight this rook cannot
move because of just Queen captures
Queen 2h8 is coming followed by rook to
d6 check which will be deadly
so here future goes for rook captures on
f3 so what happens now we have Queen 288
with check King to g6 and now well now
if you continue rook to d6 check it's
not as potent because after King
captures Bishop to d2 check you can just
give up the rook rook to e3 and after
characters characters you don't
have a way of continuing your attack
you're down a piece and you will just
lose so after a king to g6 we have Queen
Catherine's on h5 idiot decides to trade
Queens King captures and now Bishop
characters on f3 King captors in g5
unpinning and now rook to d5 attacking
the c5 pawn going after the bishop King
the f4 by Fallujah and now Bishop
captures on g4 we have King captain g4
and now rook captures and c5 we have
Bishop to d3 now defending the pawn here
and now Bishop to d2 so now I feel jazz
up a pawn but it's bishops of opposite
colors the rooks are still on the board
so they're still play of course but it's
not going to be easy to convert this
extra pawn king f3 of course grabbing
more space with the king and now rook
the e5 threatening rook to e3 check
which will win the bishop so Bishop to
e4 not allowing this and now rook
captures and b5 here it seems like with
it outplay through Jack you wanna pawn
due to this little tactic however this
couldn't be further from the truth
feel free to pause the video for a final
time and find the winning move for
Fallujah while I give you a couple of
seconds so photos of you who spotted
this this wild tactic are
congratulations
and for those who just want to enjoy a
show its rook to d7 and it's a setup you
might want to remember with the bishop
for example you have the the white king
locked down here
the bishop covers h1 that's important so
rook to d7
now you either win the bishop or the
bishop has to move of course if it it
move the bishop and now comes Luke to d1
with Czech king to h2 you don't have
access to f2 or g2 so you have to go
King H 2 and now King the g4 by Fallujah
and it was in this position that we did
resigned the game because there is no
defense against the rook to h1 mate so
it's really there are no tricks there
are no checks you could prolong the game
with some Ruby g5 pointless ideas but it
won't really make sense so after this
after this rook captures on b5 it's
really a beautiful tactic and maybe
opposition you might want to keep in
mind you if you have something like this
if you have a bishop guarding h1 or a
dark square Bishop guarding a1 or well
any other corner for that matter ideas
like this are possible even at the cost
of a pawn so after this link to g4 move
it is resigned and blitz game number 1
goes to Fallujah next game with it will
have the black pieces which which will
not be pleasant in a must-win situation
but we're gonna cover that game as well
so we're gonna see what happened there
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank John sheriff
Barros alexander located a David Cooper
Raymond young and Layton James James for
a contributor to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing with one more game
from the approaches festival playoffs
continuing the Paul Morphy saga and
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and yes the subscribers
video is almost here so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
start of your week